投資朋友
歡迎收聽早晨財經速解讀
現在是臺北時間
2026年10月5號禮拜一早上8:30
大家早安我是游庭皓
每天早上開盤前半小時
我們在這邊陪伴著各位
一起解讀國際財經新聞
時事變化
兜兜轉轉來到慕尼克過啤酒節
還有一點茫
但醉翁之意不在酒
股民之意在開盤
帶著點醉意來等開盤也是非常有趣
今天同樣跟投資朋友來追蹤
上禮拜非農就業數據爆冷之後
難道現在的升息預期
就已經完全消失了嗎
過往種種
殖利率預期的升高
現在可以靠一次的非農降溫來瓦解嗎
今天來跟投資朋友多做些觀察
畢竟上禮拜9月份哦
非農數據其實非常差勁的
結果導致的結果
居然是禮拜五
美國股市全面收高
這一次納指盤中是
一度創下了歷史新高價
終場是上漲1.19%
來到27,190點
那這一份落於預期的就業數據哦
我們待會會從不同層面來做拆解
因為它背後包括國債的問題
法債歐債的壓力
都可能是導致美國國債
壓力稍微降溫的原因
而並不是單純來自於非農就業數據
可是往好處想
不只是納指的走高
這一次就連費半的部分
AI最大巨頭輝達
誒在禮拜五盤中創下歷史新高價嘍
所以如果連輝達上方也是萬里無雲
好這一次我們知道超微還有
資安族群也同步的強勢走升
都把納斯達克指數和
費半持續的往上推
這就值得觀察了
因為從技術角度來看
的確上方已經接近沒有任何的賣壓了
如果從美債長天期殖利率來看
現在是20多年來的高點
30年期一度來到5.69%
可是費半還在飆
納指還在飆
如果細看納斯達克100指數
底下MOVE指數是債券的恐慌指數
債券這麼恐慌
但是似乎對於股票市場毫無影響
納指今年上漲幅度還是高達22%
那標普距離歷史新
高價現在也不到1%了
撐住市場核心的
很明顯就是AI和科技巨頭
現在微軟輝達蘋果在過去三個月
兩大指數是作為最重要的上漲貢獻者
你看蘋果
即便大家覺得對於iphone dou還是
沒有那麼樂觀的銷售預期
現在剛開始開賣嘛
可是還是給他相對高的評價
那市場上之所以暫時忽略高利率
其實是因為獲利的預期真的太強了
如果我們把科技業在第三季的
每股盈餘來做獲利的整體預估
大概是暴增65%
整個標普五百指數
本來也沒有表現多亮麗
瞬間到今年第三季
已經成長到24%了
那它會導致一個很直觀的效果
就是本益比
仍然以非常驚人的速度快速的下行
所以現在科技巨頭面對高利率的條件
跟2023年我們當然知道不一樣
那個時候利率才多高
可是現在的利率
10年期殖利率
5%都還是能夠扛得住
原因就來自於
不是說估值沒有做回檔
它已經很低了
低到人家覺得好像該買一點了
即便高殖利率仍然存在
我們舉例來說
你像高利率已經讓
標普500指數的本益比
5月份大概是21倍
好現在標普納指基本上都在創高嘛
那費半也幾乎要做回升了
但是呢現在只剩下19倍左右
所以科技股獲利成長
暫時把壓力給蓋住了
這個是目前最根本的主因
也就是獲利成長的速度比
美債利率成長速度所造成的
資金承壓的速度還要來得更為快速
所以硬要講
如果我們把今年3月4月的伊朗戰事
當時的前瞻本益比
拿來跟現在來做比較
現在即便我們知道納指
費半標普台股
都比今年3月4月還要來得高
可是現在的
基奇比美伊戰時還要來得低
如果你看的是本益比
看的是股價跟獲利的關係
而不是單論股價的話
誒這個就是非常有趣的一個跡象了
那再來一個好處就是誒往
7月份來看
其實科技股的籌碼算是
洗得比較乾淨一點了
因為我們知道這兩周
應該講說這兩個月
市場上其實就是一直在盤整區間
那很多沒有耐心的人已經慢慢的離開
納斯達克指數現在又
開始重返新高以後
現在隨著半導體也開始做突破
現在有三大指數
有兩大指數上方是萬里無雲
那費半呢
費半我們當然很清楚知道
好像上一輪在7月份的去
杠杆之後壓力非常大
可是現在也差不多已經
接近到歷史新高的區域了
那有沒有可能隨時爆發
新一輪的軋空行情呢
尤其現在
在最新的記憶體研究當中
供需吃緊的
看起來也沒有任何提前的跡象
至少是延到2028年了
美光甚至預估2027-2028的供需狀況
甚至比26年來得更為緊張
那輝達現在帶頭向上攻
這說明著背後的需求
包括無塵室的產能
包括記憶體產能
傳統伺服器產能
基本上還在持續的稀缺
從臺灣伺服器代工廠
現在在整個第三季哦
年營收平均是成長130%
記憶體更不用講了
韓國記憶體出口平均年成長是412%
現在第五代和第四代的雙倍數據
記憶體現貨價格仍然在持續上漲當中
而且明顯高於合約價
所以短期的供應其實還是非常緊俏的
我們把整個標普500最為強勢的個股
今年年初以來到現在的報酬
即便當時哦
跌得很慘的
在7月份的去杠杆
像Sandex
現在還是漲幅624%
莫德納是比較少數
在前幾名當中非AI股的
漲幅540%
獲得了蠻大的一個市場衝擊
不過現在的價格仍然
守在1,000塊美元之上
而且從上方來做觀察
其實也沒有什麼很具體
的大量的籌碼區的賣壓
反而下方是有所支撐的
所以你說基體行情就
正式的完全結束了嗎
從價格層面來看
套牢人似乎也不想像中來來得多了
2027年現在我們當然知道
整個發債量還在持續提升呢
哦這也讓整個費半的本益比
目前下行速度是來得最為快速的
所以真正推動看第四季行情的
一方面當然是籌碼的原因就
的確這一輪算洗得還蠻
時間算久算乾淨的
那第二就是接下來的企業買盤
還有本益比的誘因
是否會讓價值投資者開始陸續回歸哦
那第三點呢
當然就是高利率和低估
值是否能夠同時存在
進一步拉高市場的行情
畢竟現在從高估值角度來看
你也不能說它是絕對高估值
但股價的確是相對昂貴一點了
這是從體感上來說
所以高利率第一波影響的
我們如果撇開標普五百指數
撇開費城半導體指數
撇開我們看到道瓊
撇開所有四大指數
我們就看高利率最為直接影響的
應該要從羅素2,000
從中小型股來做第一波傳導
如果連羅素2,000都能夠有效的撐住
那其實這個利率的問題
看起來就沒有想像中來的大了
現在小型股
就有一點出現在那種
快要小嘎空的位置
因為羅素2,000這一波跌幅算蠻重
從高點跌下大概跌了10%左右
但關鍵是
它的長期趨勢線還是暫時守住的
而且重新占回到200日
移動平均線之上
那現在唯一的好處就是
其小型股情緒還算是蠻悲觀的啦
羅素2,000在系統性的策略鋪顯呢
大概只位於歷史的第7個百分位
超過9成時間持倉都
比現在還要來得高
這說明其實小型股在過去
一段時間是很明顯反映這種
實際利率走高之後的市場賣壓
那如果羅素2,000現在能夠重新的站穩
開始往上攻
那說明最受到高利率
影響的指數看起來
都能夠承受得住目前的高利率
這就是生產力的有效提升
那回頭看臺股也是如此
臺灣的硬體供應鏈呈現的數字
因為台股最近是創下歷史新高了
融資餘額已經連續10個交易日增長
上市融資距離歷史高點
幾乎也算是創歷史新高了
上月融資已經創歷史新高了
所以總體市值衡量來看
杠杆程度沒有超過7月份高點
可是指數創高了說明
台股本輪的創高也不是
來自於市場的投機情緒
其實就是本益比
緩步下滑之後所造成的投資買盤
價值投資買盤的提升
就來自於基本面的拉升
臺灣這一次我們看到
你像台積電3納米5納米的
產能利用率都已經超過了100%
AI的加速需求還是很強勁
所以有時候獲利提升不了
那也不是臺灣廠商的問題
訂單工廠都已經滿了
EPS能夠賺的有限的
今年美股盈餘預估
平均會成長超過50%以上
好這也使得現在台股反而
變成了費半的領頭羊
優先創下歷史新高
而且台股這一波的上漲也不是
由外資的全面追價所造成的
我們知道外資在今年美伊戰事
還有今年夏季的去杠杆
曾經大幅地去賣出臺股
目前累計的部位其實
今年以來還是偏低
今年還是賣了1.3兆可是
台股光靠自己就能夠
有效的做非常顯著拉升
然後這說明內部資金的動能呢
還是能夠做比較顯著的做吹捧的
好這就是我們觀察到的宏觀跡象
當然了
回過頭來看
那到底是什麼原因
所以導致了就連羅素2,000最容易受到
高利率衝擊的指數
就目前為止
它也能夠做有效提升呢
當然就要從這一次9月份的
非農就業數據來做觀察了
這次非農就業數據
差的離譜
只有增長2.9萬人
好這個是遠遠低於市場預期
就連8月份的新增非農也從
原本的16.2萬下修到13.3萬
好這
這代表著搞不好10月
份到時候公佈非農
又把9月份的2.9萬給下修了
每一次都校正回歸
每一次都發現就業數據比
前一個月還要來得更慘了
從7月份也從2.1萬下修到1萬人
兩個月合計比原本公佈的
數字少了接近有6萬個工作
而代表著美國的企業招聘速度
比市場先前認知的更弱
那一個如此弱化的就業數據
怎麼會變成了股票市場的利多呢
因為升息預期至少在10月份消失了嘛
這麼差的就業數據
怎麼可能立即需要升息呢
所以現在市場上變成
壞消息就是好消息
好消息就是壞消息
但不管怎麼說
任何消息對於股市都是好消息
大概是這樣子
那不叫弔詭的局面是什麼
就是家庭調查
它基本上是呈現了完全不同的畫面
從整個9月份的失業率來看
是從4.1%上行到4.2%
但是同一時間
勞動力人口增長了48.5萬個
來到1億7,026萬人
就業人口反而開始做顯著增長
如果我們看兩套官方
數據的一個追蹤
家庭調查基本上就是顯示
最近一個月大增了40.6萬人
但是企業調查就
非農調查只增長2.9萬人
這是兩個極端
家庭調查是直接問家庭有沒有工作
誒看起來還不錯
基本上沒有什麼升息
預期消失的可能性
是企業調查
他問的是這些企業家誒
你們最近有沒有招募到新的員工
我們過去講過嘛
這市場上
常常會因為下季度的不管是
在行政工作文書工作
教育工作的一個輪替
或者加上在短期內
通膨數據高升以後
也許會形成一些市場的消費資訊變化
讓大家更為去願意做兼職嘛
像我待會直播完正常了
現在是在德國
以前在臺灣
我是直播完馬上就要去送ubereat
那下午還有
那個要去加油站打工
晚上還有超市
我一個人就貢獻4份非農了嘛
那你說這叫就業市場非常好嗎
所以就業市場本來就要進行多重比較
那從這兩項數據來看
一個是家庭調查
一個是企業調查
那很明顯是
有一個地方走錯了嘛
有一點脫鉤的跡象
所以從9月份
對 還有壽司店
那有網友提醒
壽司
那是5份非農
5份非農
所以從宏觀數據來做觀察
其實整個就業數據
它不能夠保證目前就業
市場有快速降溫的跡象
這是我個人的看法
那從整個9月份平均時薪來看
這特別重要
它增長了0.1%
好這個的確就是對於通膨降溫的訊號
但是就業是不是如想像中來的弱
這個值得商榷
因為0.1%
這就比市場預估的0.3低蠻多的
年增幅也從3.1%降到了接近3%
所以從整
整體薪資通膨角度來看
的確壓力是沒這麼大了
那另外一個是產業結構
也代表著工作越來越集中
醫療保健在9月份是增長了1.7萬人
好但只有過去12個月平均
每個月增加大概3.3萬人
大約只有一半左右
那門診醫療增長1.3萬人
醫院增長1.2萬人
所以你可以大概觀察的出來
那主要也是由一些
醫療保健業來做支撐
其他領域比如說
保險業增減少了9萬人
零售業批發運輸基本上
增長幅度都是相對有限的
所以整個就業市場的概況
我們如果只用第一人稱
來看非農就業數據的話
確實很容易得到一個直覺
就是只增長2.9萬人
薪資又降到年增幅3%以下
薪資和就業都擺在這裡了
聯準會呀
不但沒有升息壓力
搞不好要降息了嘞
好這是一種角度
但是你把視角拉遠了
我們上禮拜我跟投資朋友分享
你用第三人稱來看
現在全球的資金概況
那非農就業數據
就算它真的轉弱了
它無法解決目前的美債問題為什麼
因為它背後
包括油價的問題
食品的通膨外溢效果
政府的赤字
全球軍費的暴增
AI企業的大量發債
日本資金的回流
日本在升息嘛
貿易戰供應鏈重組
聯準會的抗通膨態度
外國央行對於傳統美債的償債買盤
都在陸續退卻
這麼多宏觀原因
你可以靠非農就業數據的惡化
把實際利率硬是給拖下來嗎
其實難度是很高的好
所以我覺得這邊真正值得醒思的
不是說第一人稱或者
第三人稱哪一個比較正確你要
有第一人稱的視角來了解說哦
殖利率為什麼短期內可以下跌
為什麼市場非常歡呼
那第三人稱呢
用宏觀思維來看
它是提醒我們把鏡頭拉遠
看那些單一數據沒有
解決的結構性問題
哦就算非農是對的
也不代表著利率就會降值
因此快速下滑
好所以不要把它當成
一個史詩級的利多
你應該背後想想看
可能更多是反映AI的
估值已經消減很多
買盤又後續跟上
那這兩天剛好那個啤酒節要結束了嘛
那我就走在那慕尼克街頭
經常看到地鐵裡面
就一群男生穿皮褲嘛
那女生就穿那個緊身的胸衣還有長裙
早上
89點就已經一堆人拿著
那個巨大的啤酒杯
地鐵就拿著一瓶走來走去
到處都是嘔吐物
還有人睡在嘔吐物裡面呢
那我印象最深刻的不是啤酒了
是滿街都是這些穿著
傳統服裝的年輕人
二三十歲的男生呢
穿的這個叫做Lederhosen嘛就
皮褲很緊的那個皮褲那女穿
女生是穿那個dirndl
就是那個啤酒裝
那我就這樣搭地鐵逛街嘛
那我覺得很有趣
就是因為如果站在我的
如果是以第三人稱的視角來看呢
我會覺得唉
那一個現代的年輕人穿著
100年前的衣服會有一種錯覺
就覺得這個服裝感覺是上一輩的
必須承認的
因為我們常有一種錯覺
就覺得傳統文化
年輕人現代全球可能
參與度已經不是特別高了
臺灣其實也是這樣
臺灣國慶也快到了
那真的會一早去市政府
升旗的年輕人也沒有幾個了
要升旗都在廁所升旗了
所以如果你把鏡頭切換
到當地年輕人的第一視角
第一人稱
哎那
事情就完全不同了
一個是第三視角
一個是第一視角
他們可能就不覺得自己在復古
他也不覺得自己在模仿上一代
對他們來講
這不是上一代的文化
這是我們的文化
這就讓我想到
有時候我們常常覺得
年輕人跟上一代已經脫節了
哎手機變了嘛
工作變了
娛樂變了
生活方式也變了
可是很多底層的東西其實沒有消失
所以我們這邊講的就是第一人稱
第一視角和第三人稱第三視角的不同
有時候我們看每天的新聞呢
站在政府
站在企業勞工或者
消費者投資人的第一人稱
和我們站在外面看
整個數據的第三人稱
體感上就是不一樣嘛
人均GDP今年就準備要挑戰5萬美元了
哎那你覺得這是第一
視角還是第三視角呢
好所以從我們不同的新聞來看呢
我們不只要看發生了什麼
我們更要去看
如果我們不是旁觀者
我們是新聞裡面的那個人
我們看到的會是同一個世界嗎
哎這就是現在非農就業數據
看整個宏觀美債殖利率
利率預期升溫當中互相的角力
對我是沒有穿皮褲
但我有帶皮鞭
我們入境隨俗了
我倒沒有特別喜歡喝酒
喝口水喝口水
那之前那個老婆快生了嘛
醫生就問老公
你以前有親身看過生產嗎
那老公想了想
有
看過一次
那醫生說感覺怎麼樣呢
那老公說一開始哦
四周非常的暗
突然之間就變得非常亮
所以你要搞清楚
你到底是用第三人稱來看世界
還是第一人稱
對
不要人家問你第三人稱
你回第一人稱
人家問你
陪產經驗
你回答的是出廠記憶
你還吟詩 初極狹
才通人 複行數十步
豁然開朗
陶淵明
桃花源記
好所以
這第一人稱
第三人稱
最值得思考的地方
就是我們身處其中的人
正在處於什麼樣的一個位階
整個系統正在發生什麼樣的改變
兩者不一定誰對誰錯了
只是觀察的位置不同
這很重要
非農就業轉弱也不代表
再見問題就已經完全解決了
因為我覺得這一輪的殖利率上升呢
早就已經不是經濟太強
聯準會不降息造成的
它是一系列的原因
從軍費AI的企業債
到日本的資金回流貿易戰
聯準會外國央行的買債
一系列因素全部統合起來
才有這樣的第三視角
才是這樣的一個結果
對喝口水
感覺今天有點累
8:50了好
今天稍微聊一下美美債之後
這個是要回過頭看
美國現在包括政府財政的問題
壓力也是非常大的
從美國現在在5年期的標售情況來看
其實就大概看得出來了
好最近我們看到在5年期的標售
整體標售殖利率已經升高到5.033%
這不只是突破了5%
還創下了07年以來的最高
那投標倍數更是降到
18年以來的最低哦
隨後10年期殖利率當時
也跟著一起衝高嘛
可是都彰顯著現在
不管是長債還是短債
標售情況其實都沒有
想像中還要來得好哦
那如果往下看
等同於
當短債預期也開始做有效推升以後
它就往下游端來做真實的傳導了
下游端的直接傳導是什麼
其實就是房貸利率
我們看最近的美國30年其
房貸利率最近已經飆升到7.28%
好這個一周內從7.03飆到7.28
也算快了
這是2022年10月份以來
的最大單周升幅
當然美國是固定利率
它沒有直接性的房貸衝擊
可是直接所形成的效果是MBA的房貸
申請量正在以史詩驚人的速度下行
好最近房貸申請量在9月最後一周
直接跌了6%
連續4周下滑
部分房仲已經形容
現在全美的看房活動已經完全停止了
因為就算想買房
你也沒辦法負擔的起如此高的利率
所以美國的房市現在
同時第一就是面臨高房價
因為房價沒怎麼跌嘛
那第二是高利率
這種房貸利率無法做
複印或者說無法去順應
未來幾十年的水準了
第三就低供給
就也沒有什麼人想要賣房子為什麼
人家以前大量屋主
手上都是3%
4%的超低房貸
所以利率越高
那他們會願意換屋嗎
所以供給又減少
又讓房價難以下跌
好這個就很尷尬的情況
其實跟臺灣有點像
就房價也沒跌多少
好但利率已經慢慢在開始走升了
不過央行至少沒升息了
那供給的部分
現在市出的房源也不是特別多
好這個就是處於比較尷尬的情況
那往下做傳導
它所形成的效果是
可是美國國債的問題
至少在短期內沒有惡化
那有另外一個蹺蹺板
我們講說這國債市場
股市是這樣子
都會形成防禦性資產和
攻擊性資產的資金輪動
那在美國國債的部分呢
誒竟然在短期內賣壓沒這麼大
那是不是海外市場也是如此呢
並非如此
我們看到也許是由於歐債
尤其是法債市場的居急
所以導致了美國公債
相對賣壓沒這麼沉重
我們具體來說
你像法國的部分
現在已經變成了整個歐洲
主權債新的市場壓力
現在從法國信用狀況來看
如果政府如果無法在快速
的兩年內控制財政赤字
未來融資成本
可能會一路的失控
法國現在10年期的公債殖利率
大概已經從3.2%一路上升到4.8%
在08年以來新高
那最重要的事情不是上升
因為大家都在上升
是七大工業國當中
它是上升幅度來得最大的
現在法國10年期公債相對於
德國的公債殖利率利差
已經突破了1.2個百分點了
所以它的問題就是
它不是特別嚴重
它是比其他國家嚴重的速度來得快
這已經是2012年
歐債危機以來的罕見水準
法國現在的借款成本呢
甚至比過去被視為歐洲債務問題的
義大利還高出0.2個百分點呢
就法國的國債比義大利還便宜了
那你覺得從這樣的一個角度來看
市場上難道是認為
法國經濟差的離譜嗎
當然不是如此
是法國的財政赤字壓力實在太大了
目前已經占到GDP的5.5%
原本預估還可以壓在5%以內
目前政府
明年已經預估要提出削減
540億歐元的支出方案呢
立即削減福利支出
來穩住目前的國債市場概況
不過按照這種速度的上行
我們再看看
這個是法國國債的CDS價格
已經全面超越了當時15年
16年還有18年的水準了
直接衝往當時在12年13年的歐債危機
所以從這樣的一個角度來看
整個國債市場
即便非農稍微穩住了美債
歐洲市場壓力還是非常巨大的
我們也知道法國
這幾天新聞鬧得非常大
那爆發大革命嘛
學運幾乎已經全面失控了
一天就已經有1,900人遭到逮捕
全國大概有1,000所學校
222所遭到學生已經全面封鎖
那法國內政部也表示
上禮拜大概累積了抓
了有接近4,000人左右
那部分抗議已經演變成
縱火和街頭的衝突
那對內的部分
有這個學運的全面失控
那對外
有國債的全面壓力
好這我們就清楚知道
這個市場上對於法國的信用評級
當然會因此而做適度的鬆動
現在法國總統大選
誒其實跟
臺灣跟美國很像哦
大概只剩下7個月左右了
現在候選人多到15個
那沒辦法確定說這個右派的這蓬
一定能夠當選的
不過現在機率是最高的
所以從這樣的一個角度來看呢
法國會是否在未來一年到兩年呢
會有政策的極大轉彎
對於信用市場所造成的進一步壓力
這個是大家值得做
進一步觀察的
你說那德國國債是不是稍微好一點
是沒錯可是德國內部的經濟情況
也沒有想像中來的好
我們從德國最新的工業數據來看
7月份雖然實質訂單月增幅有2.5%
可是大部分都是政府擴大的國防支出
反而是德國最重要的汽車
產業訂單月減幅是1.7%
德國機械設備製造協會現在
從前7個月的實質產量來看
同期也下滑了4.1%
誒臺灣成長都是5成
南韓都是400%了
然後德國最強的汽車業還年減4.1%
你就可以完全瞭解汽車
已經完全是存量市場了
那面對整個中國車廠的大規模崛起
德國預估在今年總裁員規模
已經來到接近5萬個行政值
那麼預估在整體明年的裁員情況底下
本輪釋出至少會來到10萬人
現在像是福斯
BMW賓士
都有陸續的裁員計畫
進行適度的資本撙節措施
來嘗試的熬過本輪的汽車寒冬
那當然你說英國現在脫歐以後
是否情況稍微好一點
哦英債大家也可以觀察到
這個形象其實也相當壓力來得大
最近甚至
新首相博南
已經忘記是第幾個首相了
在政府準備要重新檢討跟歐盟的關係
甚至他喊出不排除
重新全面加入歐盟
他認為現在英國脫歐已經弊大於利
目前考慮的方向除了維持現狀以外
也許可以重新考慮關稅同盟
加入歐洲的單一市場
恢復歐盟會員國的身份
誒這也是工黨現在誒
工黨現在立場
重要的一個轉變
因為24年當時鄭剛
原本是明確排除要重新加入歐盟
而現在是不排除可能
要重新加入到歐盟
這也說明了他需要更多的
市場來支撐內部的經濟壓力
其主要就是來自於英國已經長期
處於低成長高支出還有高負債模式
政府支出占國內生產
毛額大概已經來到
45%哦
這個福利
這個比例真的非常高
社會福利支出一年是3,300億英鎊
人均實質國內生產毛額
大概是從19年的4.01萬英鎊
到現在才4.05萬
哎我們過去5年都已經接近翻倍了
他7年來幾乎在人均
產出沒有任何的成長
好那當然了
現在不只是法國的學運正在爆發
英國內部
也開始越來越多的檢討聲浪
我們舉一個比較直觀的效果
英國現在在疫情之後
爆發最為顯著的衝擊
就是學生的消失潮
疫情前英格蘭大約每10名學生有
一名是處於長期缺席
就缺掉10%的課程了
現在比例
是每5人就有一人長期翹課
15年到26年呢
當時超過一半課程嚴重缺席的比例
差不多最多就10%左右
現在是50%
那英國教育部的估算
長期缺席的學生到28歲以後
預估未來進入到監獄吸毒
自我傷害的風險也在快速提高
那總體預估
按照英國教育部的公佈
大概是100萬年輕人
目前處於沒有就學沒有工作
也沒有接受職業訓練的狀態
那預估未來的福利支出還有
產出損失會超過1,200億英鎊
好這個就是
在法國在英國各地
所爆發的市場衝擊好
所以這一系列的問題
所以導致歐洲債券是否
能夠有效的受到市場承接
我感覺好像比美債還更為嚴重
以前呢覺得最嚴重的是日債了
雖然日債也還好
現在第二嚴重是美債
那麼發後來發現美債也還好穩住了
現在市場上開始聚焦
到歐洲債券的問題
法國好是市場上最為擔憂的
好那不管怎麼說
整個2026年的大類資產的重新洗牌
商品價格還是漲幅第一名
有45%
那科技股續強強債
還是處於墊底的情況
不過呢
在中間我們看到幾大領域當中
基本上總體跌幅
跌最重的長債跌8%
然後其他像頭等債跌4.3%
黃金跌4.1%
其他跌幅大概0到2 %
還算正常了
主要是股票市場
如果是持有大型部位的指數
包括從納斯達克100指數
現在漲幅有兩成了
小型股一成3
中型股11 %
基本還是能夠讓今年績效
還保持著相對亮麗一點了
所以我們今天主要是講
這個債券的觀察重點呢
對於金融市場的重力
是利率往上
政府的融資成本增加
企業發債變貴
房貸變貴
股票未來獲利的折現
值當然也會跟著提高
所以最後連AI公司的估值和
資本支支出都會受到影響
可是我們要瞭解
投資真正要學到最後的
不是說單純每天多記幾個數字
我們要找到不同資產
背後的一個共同結構
今年就是商品大漲嘛
然後科技股續強
然後長天期美債重挫
那三件不同的事情呢
它背後就是幾個結構嘛
通膨成長
AI利率資金成本
大概就是這樣子
你瞭解這樣結構以後
你就不需要死背每一個音符
你就瞭解主軸就是這邊
那投資也是一樣
你不需要預測每一天的漲跌
你理解這首曲子現在
進行到哪一個段落
以及哪幾個底層變數
是正在決定它的節奏
這很重要了
這幾天我才從慕尼黑
慕尼黑回奧地利嘛
回一趟那個薩爾斯堡
就是去拜訪莫札特的故居
那走進莫札特的城市
你很難把他想像成的
因為他說天才型歌手
天才型作曲家嘛後來
我跟著一個那個導遊團
講英文的
默默跟著
沒付錢的
那聽到他講了一個概念呢
他講說莫札特的作品你拆開來看
你會發現非常強烈的數學秩序就對稱
莫札特的旋律哦
你稍微聽一下
你都大概瞭解
都是以兩小節4小節8小節的
相對規整的單位組成的
一段旋律先提出一個音樂上的問題
然後下一個再像回答一樣接回來
前面先建立張力
後面解決張力
有點像幾何圖形
再就比例
就本身它是大量建立在二分四分
八小節這些結構上
一個大段落裡面
它又可以切成更小的段落
他講的是什麼
就是其實後面在研究
莫札特的作品當中
會很常看到這種大結構包裝著小結構
很像數學裡面的階級和比例的關係
更有趣的排列組合嘛
莫札特以前不是最有名的一個
例子是他的那個音樂骰子遊戲
就是那個作曲遊戲
它的玩法就是先準備很多小節的音樂
然後再透過擲骰子的結果去
決定下一個小節要選哪一段
然後最後組合出一場完整的舞曲
然後大家聽了好開心
那這個概念很有意思
它是音樂
它是可以被拆成模組的
然後再用機率按排列
組合重新的做拼裝
好所以現在音樂到底好不好聽呢
其實背後跟數學有非常
大的相關
如果頻率比例比較簡單
比如8度是2:1嘛
那完全五度是3:2
人耳通常就會感受到
比較強烈的協和協調性的
那現在人類其實很早就發現
了這種音樂跟數學的關係
從古希臘的畢達哥拉斯學派
大家都注意到那個弦長
跟音高之間的數學比例
後來克普勒伽利略
都研究過音樂跟數學之間的關係哦
就我我講什麼
我講就是同構
就兩件看起來好像
不同資產的漲幅
但底層大家的結構其實都是一樣
數學可以説明我們理解音樂
反過來音樂也可以説明我們
理解很多原本抽象的概念
所以我們現在看到的很多通膨
AI利率資金成本
它其實背後反映的都是同一套規則
再給投資朋友做些思考了
好九點零三分了
喝口水喝口水
台股上漲1,071點
收在49,547點
看起來
這個5萬點呢
是能夠提前達陣的
但是我們本原本預估
是每個月漲1萬點的
所以到年底至少要漲到12萬點
不是了
好但是至少可以看得出來
台股到底本輪的創高
真的是由於情緒的樂觀所堆高的嗎
還是背後是由獲利的
基本面來做顯著拉升的呢
這給投資朋友多做
一些思考和留意了
好但不管怎麼看呢
現在
牛市哦它不會因為漲太久而退休的啦
它會直到支撐它的音樂停止
支撐它的音樂背後是什麼
就是AI的資本支出嘛
企業的獲利
資金的供給嘛
那當然現在殖利率高一點
資金稍微緊繃一點了
那就靠本益比的偏低
看基本面來做推升吧
那是莫札特說的嗎
音樂家不會退休
直到心中沒有音樂才停止
musicians don't retire
they stop when there's no more music in them
這好像是那個勞勃迪尼洛講的
好像是高年級實習生講的臺詞
對不是
手指有多快 分貝就有多高
那是貝多芬說的
音樂家不會退休
直到心中沒有音樂才會停止
牛市不會因為漲太多而退休
直到支撐它的音樂停止
喝口水喝口水
耳邊的音樂響起了
原來是開盤的音樂
好台股現在站穩了49,500點左右
那我們今天主要跟
投資朋友稍微梳理一下
從宏觀的債券市場的殖利率預期提升
非農就業數據稍微沖銷
可是背後的因數其實都沒有瓦解
所以高利率的利空壓力仍然存在
那有利空壓力
那這些股市是怎麼往上衝的呢
一它本益比其實已經不算高了那第二
它的獲利還在持續的做拉升
所以它是無耐性的上漲
不一定是吹捧式的
追漲式的上漲哎
在這樣的一個合流圖當中
跟今年五六月份的概況
本輪的創高
好像跟上半年又不太一樣了呢
也給投資朋友多做些參考
如果喜歡我們節目
記得幫我們訂閱
按讚加分享
我們就明天早上8點半
早晨財經速解讀再相見
祝各位投資朋友看盤順利
操盤愉快